The Enchantress is particularly
important in the story of beauty in the
Beast
however in Disney's 1991 animation she
only appears fired the stained-glass
windows during the opening prologue
Disney's 2017 reimagining of the fairy
tale expands her role casting actress
Hattie Morahan and giving her character
real time on screen throughout the movie
which means that now we can fill in some
gaps that fans have speculated about
from the animated film he began movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video I
want to delve into the character is
enchantress and explore some series
about her role in the live-action remake
of Beauty and the Beast just a quick
warning there are spoilers ahead for the
new Beauty and the Beast movie if you
haven't seen it yet if that's you tap or
click here for my spoiler free review
and come back and watch this video after
you've seen the movie so the first thing
that significantly difference in
Disney's remake is that the introductory
prologue is actually voiced by The
Enchantress herself her new narration
helps to fill in some additional
backstory about the cold-hearted and
selfish nature of the prince and how he
taxed his people heavily to pay for his
lavish parties and possessions which by
the way feels like a bit of historical
commentary given that the new movie is
set in the mid 18th century a few
decades before the French Revolution the
filmmakers decisions have the
Enchantress delivered the narration is
an interesting one because although we
don't initially know it her character is
going to be at the center of many key
moments during the new film and it also
points to her role as a sort of guiding
hand over the events of the story next
we get to actually see the
transformation of the old woman who
appears at the prince's door into the
enchantress in a scene very reminiscent
of the flashback scene from the
enchanted Christmas an animated Beauty
in the deep spin-off movie released in
1997 as well as showing the princess
transformation into the Beast the way
that the enchantress is bathed in
glowing light and appears to hover in
front of the prince is similar in both
movies as for the way she transformed
from an old woman in need of help into a
magical being that reminded me of the
fairy godmothers transformation in
Disney's 2015 live-action remake of
Cinderella indeed the idea of The
Enchantress as a sort of fairy or fairy
godmother actually connects back to the
original 18th century French story of
Beauty and the Beast by Gabrielle
Suzanne Bolivian love in fact in Vilna
of the original stories in 1746
Fairey who helps both beauty and the
beast and this fairy actually turns out
to be beauties aren't as unknown to
beauty her mother was also a fairy Bill
nerves pale also features an old fairy
who looked after the prince while his
mother the Queen was defending the
kingdom but later in the story this
wicked old fairy cursed the prince
turning him into a beast simply because
he refused to marry her Disney's
animated and live-action films combine
these different good and bad fairies
into one person the enchantress who
encompasses various aspects of their
characters and interestingly enough in
the Disney novel as old as time a
twisted tale The Enchantress is actually
Belle's mother but I wonder whether in
this live-action version of Beauty and
the Beast is the princess dead mother
who is sent The Enchantress to help
redeem her son and set him back on the
right path from which he strayed
remember in the family portrait the
princess mother is the only person whose
picture hasn't been ripped by the Beast
perhaps because she was a good influence
in the family and later as it is pot
tells us in the story it was the princes
father who turned his son bad which is
what ultimately led to the curse if
that's all true then in this film The
Enchantress is basically acting in loco
parentis in other words in the place of
a parent and by teaching the prince a
lesson is therefore fulfilling the role
his mother can no longer play now I'm
sure many of you made the connection
that the beggar woman Agatha is the same
person as the Enchantress who seems to
have disguised herself in this way so
she can move freely without the
townspeople paying her much attention
which means she can keep an eye on
events and even influence them somewhat
I guess it first appears when Gaston
points her out spell as a warning about
the consequences of what happens to
unmarried women after their fathers died
and the next time we see Agatha is when
she comes to help Maurice after Gaston
and the fool Bandhan him to the wolves
this is a moment that shows the
compassionate and kind side of the
enchantress and after she takes Maurice
back to her makeshift home in the woods
she gives him hot tea or perhaps some
magic concoction and helps him get
better by the way did you notice the owl
in these scenes it's interesting because
in medieval Europe owls were often
associated with wise women and witches
and in some symbolism they're connected
to magical forces and the idea of being
able to see beyond your immediate
reality which is a nice method
for the story of peace in the Beast now
given the owl symbolism the fact that
Agatha has won is a nice way to hint
that she's connected with the character
of The Enchantress and therefore has a
lot more power than the townspeople
would assume a beggar woman would have
with all that in mind it's also
intriguing that in the original animated
movie an owl appeared to Maurice and
Philippe just before Maurice took the
wrong turning on his way to the fair and
in the new movie given the way she
watches over events it's implied that
the Enchantress caused the lightning
strike to fell the tree that blocked
maurices path and led him into the
enchanted past the forest by the way
when I interviewed beauty in the Beast
director Bill Condon recently he told me
that the cane that the enchantress uses
at the start of the film is the same
shape as the branch that came down in
front of Marie's you could also argue
that The Enchantress guided subsequent
events that led Maurice to the beast
castle even perhaps the wolves chasing
him there and by steering Maurice
towards the castle she seems to have
been hoping to give the cursed Prince an
opportunity to interact with someone
from the outside world and redeem
himself which is what eventually happens
when he meets Belle Agatha was also
present during the mob scene observing
the events and she quietly entered a
castle during the final battle between
the mob and enchanted objects and it's
there where she witnesses the true love
Belle and beast have for each other
what's really interesting in this scene
is that Belle isn't actually the one who
breaks the curse the last petal falls
before Belle declares her love for Beast
and so the enchanted characters are
condemned to stay inanimate objects and
beast himself already appears to died
from the wounds inflicted by Gaston but
when the enchantress sees how much Belle
loves Beast
she takes control and reverses the
cursed bringing the rose petals back to
life she envelops the beast in the
petals and a magical energy that revived
him and transforms him back into his
human form then the enchanted characters
also come back to life the crumbling
castle is restored and winter melts away
to spring with the Sun rising over the
previously dark castle and grounds given
The Enchantress is guiding hand in these
events I wonder whether she also caused
the castle rampart to crumble below
Gaston feet
sending him plummeting to his death
after all at the start of the film
Gaston did use the example of Agatha and
the fact she dispensed a reduced to
begging as a way to try to control Belle
and curb her independence and he also
tried to kill Maurice and lied about
undermine agathor as a witness calling
her a filthy hag in front of the rest of
the town the decision by the filmmakers
to give more screen time to the
character of The Enchantress aka Agatha
in the new version is an interesting one
and I'm sure fans will debate her
motives and to what extent she could be
considered a good character or a cruel
one much as fans have done with their
character and the animated movie however
I do think that the filmmakers have
given the character more agency in the
live-action version beefing up her role
as a kind of subversive woman who lives
on the edge of society in its
expectations
just like the updating of Belle's
character the updating of The
Enchantress this character is in a way
in tune with real nerves original French
story which tackled themes and issues
important to eighteenth-century women
and it's also in tune with how screen
lights and Linda Woolverton wanted her
version of the tale in the animated
movie to be more relevant to
contemporary audiences by making Belle
more independent back in 1991 and I also
think that the filmmakers have made an
effort to humanize the enchantress
changing her from a character you only
see talked about inspire a stained glass
window to someone who can show
compassion at various moments in the
story and you could even argue that her
decision to curse the prints and those
around him was for the good of his
kingdom but before this he had little
love in his heart and treated his
subjects poorly taxing them excessively
as for the idea of punishing his
servants as well that fix to an extent
in the new version and it's made clear
that they were not blameless as they
didn't try to stop the prince so I'd
imagine if they'd have stood up to him
they would simply have been dismissed
however mrs. Potts does tell bells at
the servants first some responsibility
for how the prince turned out like his
cruel father who she says twisted him up
to be just like him and they did nothing
to prevent it now I'd love to know what
you thought about the enchantress and
the changes to the character in the new
version of beauty in the Beast and how
did you like the ending to the new movie
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
do hit that thumbs up button and
subscribe for more of my Disney and
Beauty and the Beast videos plus a
chance to win this awesome Disney
hardback book on my beauty in the Beast
Easter eggs video you can tap or click
here to check that out as well as other
videos you might enjoy thanks for
watching and see you next time you be
going movie lovers